Пшеничні поля - символ України, а "житниця Європи" - звичний титул.
Через блокаду Росією морських портів Україна не може
продавати зерно за кордон.
Україна виробляє значно більше зерна, ніж споживає. За даними Держстату,
у 2021 році зернові культури були другою статтею українського експорту
- тобто більше грошей у бюджет принесли тільки чорні метали.
За результатами 2021 року Україна експортувала 51 млн тонн
зернових різних видів. При цьому було отримано експортну виручку
12,3 млрд доларів. Це доволі таки значна сума,
вона становить 18 відсотків всієї експортної виручки України.
На гроші, виручені за експорт, аграрії купують насіння та добрива,
платять за оренду землі й за роботу працівникам.
Якщо ми зараз не продамо врожай минулого і цього року, то агрохолдинг
не посіє озимі. А якщо він не посіє озимі, то на наступне літо не буде що збирати.
За даними ООН, Україна годувала 400 мільйонів людей у світі.
А за обсягами експорту пшениці займала п'яте місце у світі -
після Росії, США, Канади і Франції.
Торік найбільшими покупцями українських зернових стали Китай,
Єгипет, Туреччина, Індонезія та Іспанія.
Водночас ще низка країн, здебільшого азійських та африканських,
цілком залежні від імпорту зернових культур.
Деякі з них більш ніж половину своїх потреб у пшениці
закривають завдяки Україні.
Серед усіх зернових, які продаються у світі, частка України - 10 відсотків.
Утім економіст Олег Пендзин наголошує, що для Африки, Близького Сходу
і Південної Азії українське зерно - незамінне.
Ніхто з Канади не везе зерно, припустимо, на Близький Схід.
Не тому, що неможливо, а тому що дорого.
Припустимо, Україна не вивезла своїх 20 мільйонів тонн.
Але це тих 20 мільйонів тонн, яких взяти немає звідки.
Тобто весь експорт по світу - "розмазаний", він на сьогоднішній момент
прив'язаний до традиційних ринків.
Традиційно Україна продає більше половини зібраного врожаю
зернових та олійних культур.
У 2020 році на експорт пішли 62 з 98 мільйонів тонн урожаю.
Наступний рік виявився менш вдалим - продали 49 мільйонів тонн.
А станом на липень цьогоріч на експорт пішли понад 60 мільйонів тонн
- попри чотири місяці війни.
Справа в рекордному за всю історію України врожаї зернових
і олійних культур - 106 мільйонів тонн.
Більшість продукції встигли вивезти до повномасштабного вторгнення.
Нині це основна проблема для України. Раніше більше 90 відсотків  зернових
вивозилися через морські порти, які нині заблоковані.
Від початку повномасштабної війни зерно вивозили так:
60 відсотків - через річкові порти Дунаю, 26 відсотків - залізницею,
решта (4%) - автомобільним транспортом.
Через західний кордон потяги із зерном прямують до портів Польщі й Литви,
а також в Австрію. Тривають перемовини про поставки залізницею
до портів Італії, Хорватії, Латвії, Німеччини. На залізниці є свої обмеження:
ширина колій у Європі й Україні різна, це затримує потяги на кордонах.
До того ж інфраструктура європейських портів не готова
приймати значні обсяги українського зерна.
Частина експорту припадає на фури. Але вантажівки мають ліміт ваги,
тож для перевезення великих обсягів зерна не підходять.
До того ж вони створюють додаткове навантаження на пункти пропуску на кордоні.
Після звільнення острова Зміїний можливості проходу кораблів Дунаєм
збільшилися. Судна ходять і українським, і румунським гирлами річки.
Заходять до українських портів Рені, Ізмаїл, Усть-Дунайськ, завантажуються,
виходять назад у Чорне море і прямують до портів Румунії і Болгарії.
Річкове гирло досить мілке, тому ним не можуть рухатися великі судна.
Тож ані річковий, ані залізничний транспорт не може замінити морські порти.
Зернові це доволі важкий товар і возити його залізницею чи автотранспортом
доволі економічно недоцільно. І саме використання морського транспорту
дозволяє отримати відносно дешеву логістику,
щоб бути конкурентноспроможними на світовому ринку.
Для порівняння: одне відносно невелике морське судно - це 80 тисяч тонн.
Для перевезення такого обсягу вантажу треба 3600 зерновозів,
або 40 річкових суден.
До війни Україна могла експортувати близько шести мільйонів тонн зернових.
Нині цей показник втричі менший.
За червень вдалося вивезти менше двох мільйонів тонн,
тоді як у сховищах лежать ще 18.
Саме тому експерти наголошують, що лише розблокування морських портів України
дозволить продати врожаї минулого й цього року, і посіяти озимі для наступного.